my name is xia mian I'm a physicist I
work at Princeton University in the
program on science and global security
where I've been for 20 years and my
training in physics actually in the
early 1980s overlapped with the
heightening of the Cold War and the
President Reagan and that led to many
questions being asked of scientists and
physicists in particular about nuclear
weapons and the need for the public in
democracies to be able to understand
what their governments are doing when it
comes to the threat of use of nuclear
weapons and the possibility that such
weapons would actually be catastrophic
for Humanity this is also the time that
Carl Sagan was introducing the world to
the ideas of nuclear winter and what
would happen if there was a large-scale
nuclear war between the United States
and the Soviet Union so I actually met
Carl Sagan we overlapped in several
conferences and this is a very important
time for scientists to think about their
responsibilities in democracies and if
you ask the question why scientists have
a special role in democracy then I think
the focus has to be the fact that
scientists as citizens have an
obligation to bring whatever skills and
insights they have and share it with the
rest of the citizens in their societies
and with humanity at large because we
have the privilege of being given the
time and the opportunity to devote to
understanding the way the world works
and we have an obligation to share the
understanding with everybody who's
possibly interested in that so that they
can make the best possible decisions
concerning themselves on the world they
live in and how that world is managed
and governed by those with power over it
and when it comes to nuclear weapons
this is an especially important
responsibility so I've been very
privileged all my life as a scientist to
be able to try and combine my training
in science in physics with the
responsibilities of citizenship to try
and engage citizens and people
everywhere in the debate about what
nuclear weapons mean and how humanity
can free itself from
scourge of nuclear war
[Music]
[Music]